let's see if we remember how to do this
uh three two one and record
sweet where we been at
this is your pill pod your friday your
weekend critical theory and philosophy
podcast
most fridays not the last three because
i left the province
and when we were going to record last
week the pillpot experienced an
outbreak of omnitron
we're not pointing fingers actually i
can't point fingers this is an auditory
medium so i'm pointing forward
isn't that right no it's no it's
omnicron isn't it victor
no no like unicron i'm pretty sure it's
it's omnitron
omnitron okay yeah we'll settle on that
and we have just restarted our lockdown
i looked at the um
the strictness index for covid lockdowns
and canada is right up there with china
for the the uh
the strategic level it's also
interesting how australia was really
strict and they just like decided to go
in the completely opposite direction
they were just like [ __ ] this we're
tired and they have like the most
permissive now they're just going for
straight-up hurt immunity
geez that's odd so in lieu of being
short staffed for our triumphal
resurrection you have not now heard from
us for a few weeks unless you follow
matt on twitter
or if you watch my patreon videos anyway
there's much to talk about since we last
convened there is one this is just going
to be the way it is now like a council
style format where we discuss the orders
of the day
no we just have to discuss the things
that we that we missed after that could
we format it like a council like i like
the idea of like the rivendell kind of
model being our thing well this episode
is about why democracy sucks so for now
it's an authoritarian state
um
my name's on the podcast title so there
you are we have one bright star in the
dark sky which is uh
chile elected a socialist democrat
victor i'm going to come to you later
as the as the most chilean person here
[Laughter]
besides that there are a few big media
releases
first of course is the plastic pills
video which we never got to talk about
spoiler alert um then the fourth matrix
the 12th spider-man
and this other what was that netflix one
um
[Music]
so we have we're not going to talk about
those all today but we can uh at least
uh reference
so all these releases were depressing
each in their own way uh including my
video the decline of aesthetics is being
is becoming self-aware because the thing
we were lacking as consumers this whole
time was self-awareness right
of course
anyway if we get through all that then
we have a provocative bit of political
theory to read
uh which argues that we really just need
to suspend democracy for a little while
if we want to get everything in order
sounds like a perfect solution to me
though what could go wrong
yeah yeah no that i hope we get to that
paper hot topic in the twitter theory
verse right now i should say i actually
not the word i don't know i agree with
the paper i mean we'll get into it but i
do admire that somebody at least had the
gall to write it uh because
you think to yourself like wow somebody
at some point or another was going to
get around to it you just need acquired
somebody with the right amount of
audacity and the right amount of talent
to actually put the argument forward so
and the author is chilean also well he
at least works at this person
we'll have to pick this up later so he
can actually say what we think the
author's argument was yeah i don't think
the argument is that's right are we
disagreeing agree no i disagree with it
but i do appreciate that at least
somebody
had the balls to just sit there and be
like you know what let's just [ __ ] go
there
we'll see if it works it remains
unspecified but as you know matt
disagrees all right and if you want to
see that article you can find it on
patreon.com plastic pills even if you're
not a patron this goes for most of the
public releases that we have because i
can't attach a pdf to
a spotify release
so they're there if you
like what we're talking about you want
to read the paper for yourself it's
posted there publicly breaking the
paywall ooh that is some spicy spicy law
breaking right there well i think the
journal beat him to it because it's been
uh it's i think it's been d paywall for
this oh was it okay yeah that's right i
checked the twitter today and
ross mitiga was saying that the author
anyway
all this and more coming up on today's
episode of the pillpot
[Music]
okay there's the intro we just we just
inserted it you want the good news of
the bad news you want the good news
victor because you're the most chilean
one here this news report falls to you
what happened in chile yeah so
i think is is this first name gabriel
gabriel boric uh who is of i believe
croatian descent originally um
35 years old so he's my age uh was
elected president um you're 35
yeah
uh you know i don't know that much about
chilean politics but but i i do know
that like it kind of came down to
uh two candidates and one was basically
like a bolsonaro-esque proto-fascist and
then the other one was like a socialist
boric this young socialist and he won so
we'll see how that goes
i do know though that like kind of a
less reported story is the the election
of the parliament uh and the senate
both are dominated by kind of neoliberal
centrists so i don't actually know how
much power boric is gonna have to enact
changes
that said i don't know exactly how their
legislative like process works
i know that originally they were modeled
after the united states so
based on that
that usually means that the president
doesn't have that much power to do
whatever he wants um
compared to like a canadian system where
the prime minister if he's by virtue of
being prime minister you basically
control the house so you get to pass
whatever you want i don't know how much
power he's gonna have to enact change
but it's definitely been a strong a
large like
more morale boost it's also i believe
one of the biggest margins of victory in
chilean history in a long time it was
like a 10 margin
um but on a personal note uh i will say
that um you know a lot i've mentioned
before on the podcast that a lot of my
family has kind of like some right wing
sympathies
um
and my family owns uh like a farm kind
of in the south of chile it's you know
it's not an industrial production it's a
kind of a small family farm where they
grow eucalyptus trees and pine trees and
now they've been growing some avocados
and stuff like that and
um
and they've i think it's been in my
family for close to 100 years but now i
like i actually just got a phone call
from from my mom and she was saying that
my uncle is super worried because
apparently the election of borac has
empowered
some some radical indigenous groups who
have been going and forcibly st like
retaking farms uh
so so they're worried he's actually
worried that there's gonna be violence
and that some of his neighbors have had
these indigenous groups come and present
them with papers i don't know what that
means
saying that they're that it's gonna be
their land now
so i don't know exactly what that what's
what's gonna happen with that
uh you know on the topic if we
eventually get to the paper uh it talks
a lot about legitimacy and the one
question i had was like well there must
be like some kind of due process right
and i know that there is a history in
the south of chile of kind of
illegitimate non-due process uh you know
it's possible i don't know that much
about the history of like the the
ownership of the land i know it's been
in my family for a hundred plus years
but you know it's possible i have no
idea that maybe it was taken
like unjustly and if that's the case the
landed aristocracy is worried for their
necks yeah
it reminds me a bit of that princess
bride moment uh where you see um what's
his name little ball dude sit there like
how dare you try to take what how truck
how dare you try to steal what i've
rightfully stolen right it's like
i mean i don't know though i don't know
what the what like it would be a big
assumption to say that it was taken
illegitimately i don't know that right i
mean it's possible it was it's possible
it wasn't there was a history in that
area of when pinochet came to power
where under pinochet's regime which was
in the 70s land was taken from
indigenous people illegitimately but my
family's farm was not part of that like
i said it's been in my family for over
100 years so so that it has nothing to
do with pinochet absolutely i will say
the other bit of good news is uh his
election followed the decision in 2020
to
scrap uh the pinochet air constitution
uh which is designed to be kind of the
paradigmatically
neoliberal document so child has been
scoring a lot of points lately uh and
it is kind of a bright spark uh in an
increasingly dark world so
mad props to chile for that um yeah
totally totally as you were pointing out
all joking aside there are definitely a
lot of complexities there that need to
be accounted for because i definitely
thought they think that like a
resentment-driven politics uh that
basically says screw you uh to a bunch
of people is really the best way to go
yeah cautious optimism
yeah i would say cautious optimism and
uh you know uh hopefully it leads to
some institution building that that that
is like more just and and and creates
like a more a better functioning country
that that
you know it isn't based on neoliberalism
but we'll see it remains to be soon i do
want to point out my favorite tweet
about this event uh which was from
i think it was a washington post analyst
that i responded to
uh where he just tweeted out chile don't
elect a leftist uh you don't understand
what a terrible precedent uh for
violence or corruption that is
it just immediately got piled on by
people being like yeah that's kind of
almost like sitting there and beating
the [ __ ] out of somebody being like why
did you make me do this to you chile if
you knew you weren't supposed to elect
the leftist now i have to coo you again
oh hot take alert
anyway i saw a number of different
reactions uh from center right uh
commentators that were in the same vein
and it did frustrate me a lot cause
say whatever you will about allende uh
it's not exactly like he royally screwed
the country uh and started disappearing
a whole whackle of people well for for
me it was also like and my brother and i
were talking about this over the
holidays actually and it's like yeah
even if you're like a bit suspicious of
like the latin american left as being
you know not necessarily having a good
track record of being functional
like you know when the option is that
versus cast who is like this
proto-fascist it's like it's it's not
even a choice like like you know and you
and we saw that in the results i mean we
saw that it was a 10 margin so like it
doesn't really matter you can have your
misgivings about latin american
socialists but you know there wasn't uh
the the when the option is isn't a
bolsonaro type or that i mean it's just
uh
it's not a hard decision i think that's
that's interesting to me because i hear
that south american
uh leftism is some of the strongest in
the world um well it's strong it's
strong like in terms of cultural but
like in terms of the track record of
like turning a country around to to have
functional egalitarian institutions like
i don't know how [ __ ] how how good of a
track record it's been at raising uh
like reducing income inequality and
raising people out of poverty well they
never had much of a chance you know
in this hemisphere how do you do that
with constant meddling
i'm just saying we find we can blame it
on on whatever factors and like yeah
there's validity to that but i'm i was
only saying like
you know you can have your miska like it
was kind of like giving an olive branch
to the other side and being like okay
fine like you you don't like the left
but why would how could you vote for
this other guy that's kind of the point
right it's like it's not so much like
trying to have it it's more like the cap
my brother and i were talking about this
in the context of like our uncles who we
don't agree with politically and it's
just like how could you stomach voting
for this guy cast that was kind of the
context yeah my experience with it
generally is uh something akin to like
the career of eva morales i think
morales actually did a lot of good for
the country uh and by most metrics he
actually did raise people out of poverty
but then he quickly became autocratic
and tried to run for more terms than he
should and began corroding democratic
institutions
and it's unfortunate because you think
if you just decided to leave after two
three terms uh your
praeria would have been pretty
unambiguously hailed by the left as like
a triumph yeah well speaking of
countries like chile getting back on
track after american coups and political
meddling uh honduras
actually just elected a leftist
president uh first female president
in honduras as well named
xiaomira castro who's set to take office
later in january this this has gone a
little remarked in media
interestingly enough but um
she's she out she outbid the uh the
standing right wing nationalist party
uh and one with i think one of the
highest uh
vote counts in their election history as
well so now another pretty
piece of good news
from uh south american politics another
leftist government
uh this is after the
2009 u.s aided coup that the uh standing
president um
and their party masterminded now this is
getting back on track again we see uh
we're seeing uh south america throwing
off these old uh reigns of
neo-liberalism and right-wing
nationalism that
well except for president i think it's a
good thing yeah brazil still maybe has a
bit of a ways to go um but i mean
hopefully it's a pattern that continues
on
yeah i've been following bolsonaro's
career relatively closely and what
amuses me about him more than anything
else and i'm made this comment to my
brazilian friend uh
where i was like he's basically like a
living chuck norris meme you remember
they used to have those back in the day
where it's like no germs would attack
his body because it'd be afraid of
[ __ ] chuck norris's fists or
something like that chuck norris doesn't
do push-ups
like literally the way tends to respond
to anxieties about code but it's like oh
i spent years in the military i'll be
fine you know got it
he was doing a billion push-ups isn't he
in the hospital again for like the
fourth time this year
yes he's got he's got intestinal
problems because of the stab wound he
received a couple years ago
he may be immune to germs like chuck
norris but his [ __ ] is gonna blow him up
from the inside yeah yeah so i was
actually gonna that kind of brings um
that brings to mind uh kind of like
this is this thing i was thinking about
the other day just like in general how
they're right these days
um the more reactionary write is really
like like
grabbing and running this kind of like
i don't know um
like masculinist politics this this like
politics of just like hyper masculinity
and uh it was kind of funny there's a
guy i don't know who if people are that
familiar with but there's this dude uh
uh jack murphy who's got this youtube
channel he's kind of like
part of i guess what they call the
manosphere he's got like i don't know a
million subs and he like writes about
like he has this like community called
like the liminal order and it's like
about men reclaiming their masculinity
and he talks about how he used to be an
obama voter but then like he just like
trump kind of reawakened in him
like this sort of like i don't know if
it's trump alone but anyway the point is
like he recently got cancelled by his
own uh viewers because uh
it came out that uh he had written an
article maybe in like 2018
where he talked about when he was still
anonymous people didn't know who he was
he was like on the manosphere and he
wrote an article basically arguing in
favor for the joys of cuckholding of
like having uh
having having your your girlfriend get
[ __ ] by another guy and like kind of
like the surprising enjoyment of that so
like that came out
and then all these like manusphere like
hyper masculinist right wingers where
like you trade or like how could you be
you're literally a cuck you know what i
mean
and uh so that was very very amusing um
well i have to say i've never really
engaged those ties because they kind of
frighten me a little bit just because do
you i know that any manosphere types or
actual cuckolds no that the manosphere
because every time i encounter one of
them online i just know for certain that
he has a way bigger penis than anybody
else that i know just [ __ ] like
gigantic or else why would he be there
uh and actually and i just face up to
something that intimidating and actually
the reason why that came out was because
he was on some other like right-wing
talk show
and so and this one of the the hosts
this woman was was reading kind of like
the chats or whatever on youtube
and somebody asked it's like you know
ask him about the article ask him about
the article and like she was like hey
like what's the deal with this article
and he [ __ ] lost it he literally said
[ __ ] you for asking me that how the [ __ ]
like d how the [ __ ] do you like you know
where do you get off asking me a
question like that and like his reaction
just like added like basically spilled
gasoline on the fire
mr dickenballs says hey jack see she
shits what she does she does this
like she reads it like that's normal
like it's not even i'm saying i'm gonna
skip the name she just goes mr dukenball
said could you please clear up the [ __ ]
article you wrote
i am not going to talk about this and
basically you know what [ __ ] you
for bringing this up right here and
right now why why are you doing this to
me i didn't know that i didn't know what
it was well just use a little bit of
[ __ ] common sense sorry apologies
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you elizabeth
heartfelt elizabeth uh harrison says
gonna gonna miss the show but have a
good break i htac what's that
[Laughter]
what
nothing i'm just guy i literally just
coughing it's just an inconvenient cop
yeah
oh my god well that's what i say when
people ask me about my master's research
paper anyway so it's not such an unusual
reaction
we all know that the best way to respond
to anybody who's trying to troll you on
the internet is to really blow up get
extremely angry uh and just start
ranting and raving about everyone and
everything that's guaranteed to make you
look cool that's how you come off the
best
i'm pretty scared of that big dick
energy to be honest i'm too much of a
coward to
tell a woman [ __ ] you to her face
i need that i need that brave dick
energy yeah well understandably right
like you just watch them and you're like
man that guy just
slays with women slays in life uh
probably's got a fat bank account
there's no way i can compete with that
yeah i'm wracked with anxiety around men
like that my hands shake
they are this master signifier they're
the non-castrated purely positive
signification there's nothing above that
skeletons won't stay in the closet
anymore they're ruining good manosphere
careers
the way back machine
is cancel culture yes you can't can't
write a paper about your wife getting
[ __ ] by another man without the entire
bro squad finding out well even if he
loses
if he loses his entire following his his
youtube career he's still got that big
dick i'd also like to send a shout out
to all of our listeners and just remind
you that we are a sex positive channel
so if your idea of a good time is
watching your partner uh get [ __ ] by
anyone or indeed anything else uh we
strongly encourage you to do it and feel
no shame at that we are not we are not a
sex positive channel
we've never addressed this we've never
i'm asexual
you're anti okay fair enough i'm
anti-sexual not anti-sexual not
anti-just a body liberated from its
organs and i don't want to hear about
yours neither
aunties we're an anti-sexual podcast
that'll get us fired
[Laughter]
all right all right that's the new way
no sex ever and don't jack off either
because it'll ruin your energy
no fap
hey that's what emanuel kant told me to
do as long as i'm not married i'm not
allowed to so i take him at his word on
that cobra kai teaches abstinence
right
so what's next what's next i think we
have uh well i want to talk about your
video bills cause we didn't get a chance
to talk about it
i'm glad that you said that because
otherwise it sounds like i just want to
advertise my videos you actually have
something to say about it so you know i
think
i just think it was like a very salient
critique and
i was interested in a lot of the
reaction to the video so obviously like
for those who haven't seen it although
i'm assuming if you're a listener
there's a good chance
you know you've watched it and i think
you you very nicely uh like i didn't
even know that the cia report existed
right a cia report i guess when was the
report written
it was it in the 85 the 80s right there
so they looked into radical leftist
theory right to kind of see the extent
of which it might be a threat french
french specifically and i think they
concluded it very amusingly that and i
think probably plausibly that it's
really uh not a threat if anything it's
kind of helping them and it's like we
don't need to worry about radical
theorists because they're not really a
threat anymore right after the failure
of of may 68 in france
and kind of like
the and i think you know what's
interesting to me is like
you know one of my reactions to it is
you know in some ways like the these
french theorists i feel like they're
intellectually it's a sign that they're
intellectually honest because i think
that if you're an intellectually honest
thinking person and like you see what
happened in the soviet union you kind of
have to
like uh revise i think right like to me
i was like of course they will these are
smart people who are thoughtful
and they saw what happened and yeah it's
gonna lead to
it's gonna lead to this internal debate
uh theoretical debate but to me that's
just a sign that these people
these these theorists they were never
meant to be um you know uh like their
primary role was not meant to be praxis
you know it's theory they're theorists
they're thinking about these things and
when you think and that's like the main
thing that you do it's hard to avoid uh
it's hard to ignore these things and
just be like no we have to act no matter
what it doesn't matter screw what the
soviet union might have done screw all
these other things we have to act and
it's like well of course they're not
doing that they're theorists first right
so of course they're gonna think these
things through carefully and realize
they have to revise their thinking and
yeah that's going to lead to infighting
and uh you know so that was kind of one
of my thoughts about it the athenians
did think they had to kill socrates well
he was annoying and he just killed
himself first nobody likes him coming
around asking a bunch of questions that
nobody wanted answering uh
but i thought the most interesting part
of your video that uh kind of speaks to
your point victor was when you were
talking about al thuzair and the may 68
strike because i didn't know the fact of
this that um i didn't know that he was a
member of the communist party uh in
france and that he was pretty active and
occasionally could be a little too
acquiescent to the soviet union but i
had no idea that he told the students to
shut it down in may uh when they got
some concessions um on labor rights and
wage increases
and they said we want to carry on and
see if we can actually enact something
like a genuine revolution and his
response to them how did you describe it
was uh to characterize them all as like
pure isle adolescence uh without a brain
in their body and that they should go
home uh and just accept what they've got
which is really counterintuitive when
you think of the radical kind of tone of
a lot of although there's writing
yeah well this is there had a mental
breakdown um
he struggled with depression and i guess
some sort of psychosis through his life
and he was in the hospital when that
happened but he wrote in a journal
article in pulsar after that you know
the kids had gotten out of hand
because he was like he was a loyalist
right he said
he kind of didn't even remark on the
morality of uh of the french communist
party he just said i'm a french
communist party member and you all
should be too it wasn't even like let's
evaluate these claims and in a sense you
gotta you know give some respect to that
because it's fidelity um but in another
sense that alienated him from
the younger generation especially the
the dudes that we talk about a little
more often of course the thing everyone
knows about althouse he supposedly
killed his wife
oh yes got away with murder yeah he did
he did actually my um
kind of my mentor and undergradual dean
finn her her main book that she wrote as
an academic was a collection of her
essays and it was literally called why
although killed his wife
what
yeah
was he in a psychotic break because
that's what
that's what they argued it's
that's what they are getting that
actually happened i mean she found that
reasoning quite disgusting that that
there were all these all these french
intellectual men who who came and tried
to justify his actions uh and like make
excuses for him
um
i don't remember one of her essays in
the book is actually like directly
addresses uh like that question and like
kind of goes through the reactions among
other french intellectuals to the
incident of him killing his wife
so i don't i can't remember it's been a
while but so i can't really remember the
details but i do know that the framing
of her essay was definitely uh very
negative of the reaction to him
murdering his wife yeah he pled insanity
but just just to bring it back anyway is
what i love about videos
like this too is it gives you that
context of may 68 right because as we
get sort of farther and farther away
from that historical moment we tend to
forget about the actual context of these
people's ideas and that may 68 was a
huge turning point in the history of
french thought right like you never
think about how different was like
sartre and beauvoir and merlot ponte
this sort of more like 50s and early 60s
fame academics versus the sort of
post-68
wave of of academics obviously there's a
lot who traverse that boundary but then
the new generation afterwards
that the video kind of enumerates anyway
is is
it's just really easy to forget how
important these historical events are
and when we read in the kind of theory
vacuum when we're trying to learn all
this stuff
it just makes that's what i love about
these videos too is that they put this
stuff into context even though it wasn't
the point of the video
yeah the sort of cia lessons part i i
totally agree i mean it because i was
writing a chapter or also on the radical
democratic theory theory tradition
uh it was useful to you to have that
context because i know that they also
like you know chantal moof and lacrow
and all these people like they really
were also in that context of post
68 kind of like
uh reeling from it and trying to figure
out uh what to do next and i think their
answer ended up being ultimately
unconvincing but i think they're part of
that whole conversation
um i wanted to yeah go ahead no it's
gonna say it's not like uh these
theories are allowing us to forget that
uh and i appreciate that uh like i made
you wrote a nice little book uh i don't
really care for his metaphysics but this
was really enjoyable called pantheon
which was about the history of
contemporary french philosophy and he
framed it explicitly uh in terms of
reactions to me in 1968
and actually it was kind of nice and
even touching because at the end he said
i'm really the last one alive from that
generation uh who has to carry the torch
forward uh yeah and i kind of sat there
thinking i'm like i don't know balabar
is still here you know but yeah
fair enough you know so
dwindling so i was curious pills about
what your sort of also your impetus for
making the video how did that come about
what was it what was your main kind of
like what was the in intent behind maybe
he's a cii plant and we just don't know
it because he's under such deep cover
because i wanna i wanna ask i want i
wanna hear about that from you and i
also wanna talk about the reaction to
the video in the comments too there's
some good stuff in there yeah i'd like
to look at the reaction too i think the
reaction is more interesting as a as a
text but as to the impetus i mean it's
not just one thing there's a bunch of
things
you guys probably know what
more than one of those things is i don't
really want to say it on air oh okay was
that
okay fair enough let's just say it's an
encouragement for everyone including us
to get our heads out of our own asses
yeah fair enough fair enough uh i mean
you could say
i mean for me the point really was the
way that the left is doing a fine job
destroying itself and the cia seem to
recognize that and repeat some of the
things that we tend to say today about
post-modern theory is that it's
too wordy too complex abstract vocab is
crazy they just said the same sort of
thing like it's too it's not clear it's
it's a really abstract and detached it's
not going to have any kind of political
efficacy so we could say safe to ignore
yeah we also get we also get like uh
pejorative comments about our about this
podcast that were to like sock damn me
i'm not sure what that means that's
mainly processed
that's mainly matt and i's fault
like that's the thing matt's the most
politically active the only the one that
like actually does organization on the
regs and like
talks to people so do you want politics
or you just want ideas and then if you
actually try to do politics then
sockden's a pretty good option they
don't just want ideas though they want
edgy ideas and like radical ideas yeah i
mean that's the kind of recurring joke
that we came like i mean
yo i took credit for that joke but i
think it was actually uh matt's
originally no it's me and victor because
i mean this this was kind of our
cheeky commentary on a lot of this
literature right where you always end
with we need an ever more radical
critique
and then you know of course what you
really just get is somebody kind of
blending nietzsche and marks together
and claiming to overcome both of them uh
shape or form and don't get me wrong i
mean i love all the people that were
discussed in the video also and it
really hurt to actually hear them
described in the way the cia described
because i've spent my time going through
my author's errors because and stuff
but it's definitely hard to get a sense
that it accomplishes that much on the
ground if you're looking at things in
terms of
tangible impact and i think you put it
really well pills where you pointed out
that it's not like we shouldn't do
theory it's an absolutely critical
enterprise but you do need to at least
make some efforts to try to take that
theory and bring it down to something
that's tangible for ordinary people like
you described it in terms of policy
maybe we don't want to use that term but
i think that's a pretty accurate way of
describing it right yeah if you adopt
this kind of theoretical perspective or
this ideological perspective sooner or
later there'll be better schools better
hospitals fewer people like elon musk
wasting money building dick-shaped
rocket ships to go to the world to the
moon uh when the world is burning you
know yeah all that kind of stuff well
the political shift was amazing that
happened because you know before that
period right intellectuals in france had
the ear of the government and a lot of
the government's policies had this sort
of
implicit at least intellectual kind of
patent on it right like this this policy
has been evaluated by so and so in this
community of intellectuals and they give
it the go-ahead and then after 68 too
they start to lose the sort of the ear
of the government really
and then by the 70s you sort of have
academia and moving off in its own
direction and not you know you have all
these divisions that emerge that i
thought the video describes that really
well
and then you get these points in history
too on the sock dem point where the
difference emerges between social
democrats and communists because there's
these points in history you can look at
where that division becomes clear they
tend to mingle with one another right
but when you look at
say the moment of um 1968 of course when
i guess it was the social democrats
and the communists the social democrat i
don't know one group wanted to
accede to the
demand or the the pay rise and say that
was good enough and stop and others
wanted to say no to that and keep going
with the protests but ultimately you
know the communist parties folded so we
don't we don't support the protests
anymore we've taken this pay rise and
running with it that's one of those
moments i guess when social i'm not sure
where the lines fall there but if you
look earlier at germany
during the sort of treaty of versailles
time you again had the sort of
communists and the social democrats and
the social democrats wanted to
you know
ally with the liberals and you know
reconcile
basically with the really really harsh
measures of versailles whereas the more
you know hardliner communists didn't
want to do that and then again you get
this sort of
big division emerge and now today it
seems kind of just common parlance on
the internet if you're not radical
enough then you're a sock damn or a rad
lady or whatever
but i mean there's no clear distinctions
in times of
relative quietude we all intermingle and
then in crisis times these
divisions start to emerge and become
very problematic
yeah yeah you can see it almost in the
writing of this report the cia report as
a sigh of relief because they describe
they describe in the past tense how
it wasn't
it wasn't just that the intellectuals
were important it was like
the everyday person knew what the
intellectuals were saying they were part
of the debate they were concerned that
their intellectuals had signed off on
government policy before the government
could do policy so the government how
many people showed up to
church's funeral you said like 50 000 or
something like that 50 or
yeah that's crazy so that's celebrity
numbers
yeah there were celebrity numbers but
more importantly the government knew
that they had to listen to
these public intellectuals because the
regular person was so if the if the
public intellectual came out against
your government then you would lose
support so they had to
but then after this was the huge
division here is after this point they
no longer had to now it was like lacan
is doing his tv special deliz is going
on tv and doing the abcs of dillas or
whatever and this became yeah the cias
is a media event and that's why it feels
like a breath of
relief from this on the part of the cia
because they're like well the government
doesn't have to do this anymore because
people aren't paying attention anymore
now it's kind of just a
uh a novelty and the other thing that i
learned from this that i didn't know was
the
scandinavian or they describe it as
scandinavian intellectuals german or
west german intellectuals they were all
taking a lead from the french so after
this happened in france
um
then you know it it collapsed a more
general european critical left then
rather just the uh the french left yeah
well then they get away they literally
said in that report now we can get away
with what we want in latin america
yeah yeah i know for sure it was yeah i
mean it was astounding uh to to read
after watching your video i did i did go
and actually read uh the report myself
it's pretty short um it's it's an
interesting read but um
i g i was also kind of curious
you know how pills how does this sort of
fit
into i guess i see it and you can you
can tell me like where i'm going wrong
or right you know i sort of see this
video as
part and parcel to what i sort of call
the the pills doctrine of you know like
ideas don't matter or you know kind of
thing it's like and i guess you know how
do you it i guess it's it's further
evidence of of this like broad claim and
maybe you can explain what you mean when
you say ideas don't matter and like the
context that it's come up if you want um
i think it could be interesting
but
you know also
maybe your message because i know that
you love a lot of these theorists right
that you're talking about and like and
for you i wonder personally like you
know the reason you like these theorists
right isn't because their ideas matter
for action in a way but because they're
just more interesting they're just you
know they're they're more thoughtful
they're more creative
uh and like when you know when you say
ideas don't matter you're obviously not
saying you know don't read these
theorists or like in fact you love these
theorists but like so i don't know if
that that that's kind of an incoherent
question but i was kind of trying to put
these pieces in my mind together uh uh
i i think the canonical pills
doctrine the statement of faith is gonna
be ideas don't matter asterisks
yeah and the asterisks there will do all
the work so
practice the ideas practice thinking
practice the
difficulty and creativity they're in but
they're not there for their own sake
it's the asterix or the remainder there
what happens five seconds after you've
read a book
matters
more than how well you can recite what
you've read in a book
um
because i yeah obviously all that's true
i find those to be the most interesting
but this one similar to how i did the uh
the chile video
i
knew what the reaction was gonna be and
i knew it was gonna be
a litmus test
and everyone's gonna find
what they already believe in that video
yeah so that's i think the response is
more interesting than the video itself
because
uh i don't know if we break it down into
like quarters
25 are like look postmodernism shitty
they should never have broken with the
marxist party they should never have
broken with the comm intern this is why
marxism failed in france
and then another quarter is like well
good thing they got a god away from
those soviets because if it were led by
the soviets they were murdering people
in czechoslovakia of course that was an
immoral
grounds for
actually existing communism etc etc what
did you guys see in the response is
there well i mean yeah that's classic it
reminded me of of when you released your
chili video
you know my favorite responses were like
fidel castro was right you know like
like that's another hyena
which maybe that'll actually lead into
potentially our discussion about
political legitimacy but it's like you
know yes you should have taken power you
know when you had the chance you know
and like screw these democratic
institutions that's why it's so dumb to
do it that way yeah shutting down the
right-wing press there would be exactly
like the
the key issue exactly so so i think like
you know we saw similar reactions here
where it's like yeah of course you know
these
the the marxists the doctrinaire
marxists i think to saw your video and
they were like exactly of course
of course as soon as you go away from
marxism
it's useless
since 1989 at the very least what we've
seen is the left increasingly become
really puritanical
and very intellectually minded not
because uh we feel that there's any kind
of opportunity to actually see our ideas
instantiated but precisely because we
don't think it's really possible that
we're going to see them instantiated the
leftists kind of adopted this very
defensive
almost scholastic posture of being
permanently in opposition
and you see that in a lot of the kind of
debates that we fixate on which are very
abstract deeply removed from policy
issues and don't really engage normal
people
all that often
and i don't know if you agree but it's
one of the things that i took away from
the report and it did also make me think
a little bit about some of the things we
said about academics because
one of the things that i find
frustrating about the left is precisely
that it is so dominated by people like
us academics and there's nothing wrong
with that because i think academic
theorizing is really important otherwise
i wouldn't do it uh but you do see the
kind of aesthetics and value systems
associated with ident with academia
really start to pollinate uh the left
generally
i mean one of the few kind of
hierarchical comments that's still
acceptable in left-wing circles is some
combination of i'm smarter than you or
i'm better read than you because that's
the kind of thing that academics value
and that's not the kind of thing i think
we should be valuing as radicals or
progressives uh definitely we want to do
the highfalutin theory we should be
doing the highest of higher pollutant
theories so we absolutely need to find a
way to bring it down to ordinary people
and say like look this is what it's
going to mean tangibly if you try to
change society in these kinds of ways
and this is what your life will look
like five years down the line if you
actually decide to support a democratic
socialist candidate bernie sanders
whoever right and we really don't do a
good job of that because too many of us
spend a great deal of time deciding
whether or not we should be sock dems or
a marxist or humanist marxist or
whatever it happens to be
i i think that there's a bad metaphor
kind of latent in there that says we
have to bring it down
to regular people i think that's like it
should already
be there if it is even useful
to
the doctrine that we're saying we hold
to in the first place
arguing whether over
the lint that fell out of marx's toes
and which direction it fell i it's it's
stupid
even according to marx
well it reminds me he wrote a letter in
1847 that no one else has seen before
and that explains his whole theory yeah
once that letter is published your
entire interpretation of his work will
all change and you'll realize that i was
right all along what reminds me of when
we did our episode on on marilla and
marxism a little bit right where
it's like
you know like it needs to be brought
down to to the people or whatever and i
think like you know i think what
mariluponte does pretty well in those
passages we read is just talk about how
you know revolutionary action is not
something that's going to come because
you have the right ideas but because of
like how your phenomenal world
presents itself for necessities and
opportunities for action
and that like you know the ideas and
like arguing over nitpicking like what
ideas but rather like your lived world
and like what do you not have what do
you have like that's kind of the source
of action um
yeah that's why phenomenology is first
philosophy and we need to start in the
sense that is common before doing
philosophy not do philosophy first and
then try to trickle down
to common sense yeah a lot of a lot
sorry a lot of this depends really
importantly on why exactly theory became
so obscure in the 1970s after this
moment i mean it's it's not an easy
thing to explain right because
you know the the idea that yeah you need
to bring it down and make it
understandable and make it applicable to
policy is
obviously really important
and a lot of you know political science
and analytic philosophy is designed for
that precise purpose
for its applicability the
operalization of its contents
of its concepts and ideas
operationalize them easily but why this
really abstract obscure theater movement
in theory as well how do you explain it
like one take i could think of off the
top of my head is that you know in in 68
they tried to take marxist ideas and
operationalize them and it failed
therefore we need to go to more obscure
language so that this doesn't happen
again because when you operationalize
ideas and they fail it casts doubt on
the theory itself
so we need to avoid that and i've also
heard that said about a door note and
and some of the frankfurt scholars as
well why do you write with such a
strange and obscure style it's because i
don't want we don't want our ideas to be
so clear that people can just grab them
take them out of context run with them
and apply them and then there'll be
disastrous results and it will reflect
badly on the on the op on the original
poster of the ideas right
so that i mean that's just one way of
construing it i don't know if that's the
right way but there's got to be some
bunch of explanations like that that
legitimate why
you know
theory took the turn it did in
what is now post-modern theory right and
to obscurity and abstraction as opposed
to
as opposed to what you might expect
which would be a
move towards clarity
and concision and
and all that sort of stuff right why
didn't that happen and as opposed to
what did happen which is you know we got
post-structuralism and crazy stuff like
that yeah i say can i say it first
before we go like i'm not saying
all philosophy should have something to
do with policy i don't know anything
about policy yeah i probably never will
what i think philosophy is for here
though is
telling someone
you already care about this you just
don't have like this specialized
vocabulary then you work up to the
specialized vocabulary because it's
something that people already care about
and they might care about in different
ways that's why you have different
philosophies they might have different
emphases that's why you have different
streams of critical theory but i think
even critical theory or
post-structuralism as at its most
abstract is still
starting with something that everybody
cares about no matter who you're talking
about
yeah for sure for sure i i want to frame
it somewhat differently though because
what i found is
there there tends to be this dialectic
that occurs uh in highly
intellectualized forms of political
agitation where on the one hand people
theorize about these ever more radical
kind of transformations of society
and
then you know because their primary
purpose is to be intellectuals they
think the easiest way to achieve that is
through some kind of revolutionary break
and there's a lot of things about the
aesthetics of revolutionary that are
very prominent in the literature and i'm
not anti-revolutionary in the sense that
i don't think we should ever have a
revolution uh i think we should uh but
the point that i'm trying to get at with
this is sometimes all this kind of
theorizing and the transition from
thinking that the idealized kind of
theorizing in your head can only be
achieved through evolutionary agitation
leads us to be uninterested in the
everyday usually pretty banal activities
that form a lot of normal politics like
any kind of activism that i've engaged
in has usually involved getting a lot of
coffee getting toilet paper
handing out pamphlets dealing with an
awful lot of trollish people uh who
don't want to talk to you uh repeating
slogans over and over and over again uh
and
that's a lot of what you have to do and
it's usually pretty boring and it's not
very intellectually fulfilling but it's
a necessary part of the process of
trying to get people agitated and
convinced that we need to do something
about the world
and i think part of the problem with
focusing exclusively on theory as the
site for left-wing activism right now is
it leads people to dismiss a lot of
these kinds of efforts as either beneath
them or not really interesting or not
like sufficiently fulfilling and we
shouldn't be doing that we should be
doing a lot more to try to emphasize how
important it is for people to get
involved
and to get their hands dirty on the
ground even if it's not the most
exciting thing in the world and even if
it means you're probably going to have
to wait a long while damn time
to see any kind of results
i think about the recent victory in
chile i imagine that took years and
years of activism door knocking tweeting
you name it in order to achieve
yeah yeah i mean i think just to add to
that too like you know i i think
you know part of the part of i guess the
danger of theory uh is is that like it
kind of well we've talked about this
before but but i think it just does
tempt people towards
a kind of purity where where because the
theory i think you're you talk about
like optimal conditions and like
i think actually going out and doing
like the organizing and door knocking
and it's like okay well whatever that's
like best case scenario that's gonna be
like an ndp government in canada right
that's just gonna be socked in [ __ ]
it's like best so it's just like why
bother because it's not gonna be like
the thing and i think theory
does have a tendency can have a tendency
leftist theory uh to to just lead to
that mindset where it's like what's the
point of doing that because it's just
gonna like you know you're you're almost
you're actually just
you know authorizing the existing power
structures by participating in them
right like it can lead to that mindset
not always and i don't know
ideas don't matter asterix
the asterix is theory is not the goal
theory is the thing that wakes you up to
the things you actually care about you
never got a chance to because of the
ideological apparatus that is your heir
at the moment
yeah and i'll be the first to say like i
prefer doing the theory myself as i
imagine most intellectual types do uh to
a lot of that activism because it is so
intellectually banal in a certain sense
uh like during the election campaign 90
of what i did was just telling people
okay everyone let's gather together and
i want you to call 10 friends of yours
and you tell them to get out there and
you vote ndp and if you have any
questions get back in touch with me
because i got a million slogans ready
for you to answer any of their questions
like it's really rote and pretty boring
but it did make an impact you know we
got some people to sign up they agreed
to vote for the new democratic party we
changed a few minds on environmental
issues but it was not stimulating in any
kind of way
although it did cause a lot of damage to
my face because i had to smile so much
which isn't like me right
and i think you know
i can understand therefore why it is
that people would be reticent to do this
kind of stuff or think it's not
necessarily beneath them but not
necessarily what they want to do
but i think it shouldn't be dismissed
either or invisibilized because i think
a lot more people in theory circles need
to appreciate
all the effort that goes in uh by
activists uh to try to actually bring a
little bit of their dreams into fruition
i think i knew i knew a woman who just
all she did for 20 years was bring
pencils to girls uh in chile sorry not
uh chile in south america that's all she
did uh and she probably helped thousands
and thousands of girls by bringing them
pencils but it's not glamorous activity
right i mean that point is really
important for whether or not you have
reform or revolution in mind because
both take
loads and loads of on-the-ground
organizing and preparation
and setting up things
that will
continue on into the future say after
the revolution or things that will you
know ensure the reforms don't get
compromised into oblivion on the on the
senate floor right do you ever think
that like that dichotomy between reform
and revolution is like problematic like
like i feel like
i guess i often think to myself sounds
like someone's destined for the gulag
there with that kind of talk yeah i mean
i think
reform versus revolution is not
dependent on the actions of the actors
it's dependent upon the conditions that
are influencing like an entire and
enough people to decide that reform or
revolution is necessary yeah i mean it's
not just like we spontaneously agree to
do a revolution and then do it that's
never happened once i mean that that's
kind of very close to badges uh kind of
messianic
theater to the evolutionary events well
i did i just i just mean like i thought
i remember talking about this maybe with
it might have been with those like um
uh the uh what are they called the the
vanguard dudes
they're they they're that these like and
and i think
you know the feminists
no they're just like these youtubers uh
who who like who are kind of like left
it like leftists and and like are kind
of like very anti-reform and like
pro-revolution whatever that means right
and and i think you know i i
the example like the concrete example i
often like talk about is like you know
the reason i was interested in andrew
yang's like ubi policy of like bringing
in ubi
a lot of leftists were critical of it
because they were like oh it's like it's
it's justified according to like
economic rationality so like you know we
should we should go away from it and
it's like yeah maybe but i guess the way
i always look at it is like if there was
a ubi
it's like that that's that's going to
create conditions to make like further
revolutionary action easier right like
when you give people more means
like everybody more means where they can
just like quit their job if they don't
like it because there's like a ubi or
something like that more power
it just like enables people it creates
more revolutionary potential i guess
it's my argument so i often feel like
reform and revolution like are
interlinked because like reforms
could make the possibility for
revolution like there there might be a
condition of possibility for yeah baskar
sincaro has a really good example that
speaks to your point uh in his book uh
the socialist manifesto which i think
everyone should read he's the editor of
jacobin uh and he was actually on uh
the channel not too long ago a fairly
long time ago yeah fairly long time ago
long story short though but one of the
things that he points out is oftentimes
uh the nordic model uh is
under-appreciated when it comes to
revolutionary potential because the kind
of story told about it is uh there were
revolutionary movements in scandinavia
they compromised on social democracy and
then eventually neoliberalism took place
because they didn't go far enough uh
actually one of the things that he
points out is in the 1970s uh there were
many workers movements that wanted to go
beyond social democracy uh towards
something like workplace democracy right
where workers would actually own their
companies and there was a big push on
their part to use the resources given to
them by social democratic settings to
agitate for that
but the state eventually said no because
it decided to side with capital instead
and there was a big push back against
workers movements which included rolling
back social democracy because they said
people have too much resources and too
many too much time on their hands uh so
they're starting to get uppity uh we
need to just push the whole thing back
and one of the points that he's making
is you don't necessarily if you look at
this as a paradigm example you don't
necessarily see need to see social
democracy as compromised with capital it
can be laying the stage for a more
sustained confrontation later on we just
have to try to be more successful
than the nordic countries were in the
1970s and actually pushed through
towards something like workplace
democracy or five minutes past
capitalism or whatever you want to call
it right uh and i think you can see a
lot of examples of that where people use
the resources of reform to try to
agitate for more reforms and more
radical kinds of reform right all right
this is a topic
that is uh rich of course revolution
versus reformation is a step in the
right direction bad or should we just
accelerate
reference identification
that's the job of theory right is to
extract concepts and purify them and put
them into opposition with one another
reform and revolution whether they go
together in reality they can be
separated in theory just like democracy
and authoritarianism are two extremely
opposed concepts in everybody's mind
they could they need to be deconstructed
they need to everything
thank you for helping me with that
segway eric yeah democracy
or authoritarianism so we are going
right after talking about what will beat
climate change
right after talking about actually
existing theory we're now going to talk
about theory theory
and something that i think we need to be
asking a lot more often um this is
maybe we'll talk about we'll talk about
uh don't look up
later i think maybe a different episode
maybe on the patreon episode that will
make sense yeah we'll do a movie we'll
do it maybe we'll get into this one
don't look what movie you works with
this article which is
written by ross media at chile a
catholic i don't know the catholic
university in chile pontifico something
something yeah it's it's like it's the
most prestigious university in chile
pontifico universidad de chile
and he's a junior scholar right he's an
assistant professor and he says if we're
going to do
what can if we're going to address
climate change i'll give you the one
sentence okay then you can introduce all
the context if we're going to do
climate change
democracy has proven that it's not gonna
work so we should reintroduce the
conversation of authoritarianism as a
way to
prevent us from all going extinct all
right yeah victor to you okay okay so i
did i mean this is an article that
fascinated me like as someone who's in a
political science department uh in the
political theory world like i follow a
lot of people on twitter so when this
article came out
like the political theory world the
political science world kind of went
crazy uh because it was published in
sort of like the premier journal uh in
political science the american political
science review it's like considered kind
of the most prestigious journal
and it's called political legitimacy
authoritarianism and climate change and
i think
there was a lot of like reaction to it a
lot of people were outraged that he was
suggesting that maybe we can justify
authoritarianism so i thought that the
article would just be like an
interesting thing for us to discuss
in kind of the context of talking about
um you know political action
and um i mean maybe i'll just read the
abstract quickly because that kind of
like gives you an idea i think it's like
a little bit more nuanced uh than what
pills said i actually thought the
argument itself was
in a way obvious like so so like
but because it's focused on this
question of political legitimacy so just
we're reading the abstract um it is
authoritarian power ever legitimate the
contemporary political theory literature
which largely conceptualizes legitimacy
in terms of democracy or basic rights
would seem to suggest not i argue
however that there exists another
overlooked aspect of legitimacy
concerning a government's ability to
ensure safety and security while under
normal conditions maintaining democracy
and rights is typically compatible with
guaranteeing safety in emergency
situations conflicts between these two
aspects of legitimacy can and often do
arise a salient example of this is the
covit-19 pandemic during which severe
limitations on free movement and
association have become legitimate
techniques of government
uh climate change poses an even greater
threat to public safety consequently i
argue legitimacy may require a similarly
authoritarian approach while unsettling
this suggests the political importance
of climate action uh for if we wish to
avoid legitimating authoritarian power
we must act to prevent
crises from arising that can only be
resolved by such means so you know i
think the argument he's really making
and he sets it up uh i guess like before
we open the discussion i kind of just
want to mention he he sets it up by
talking about two different forms of
political legitimacy which by the way i
think political legitimacy is like a
really interesting and important concept
to think about if we're like interested
in politics and he he he frames it
around two ideas one he calls
um
uh foundational legitimacy uh and the
other he calls contingent legitimacy and
he basically says foundational
legitimacy he argues and maybe we'll
have issues with this
is you know like the duty of a
government to basically maintain order
and safety is like the foundational
legitimacy because but without that
you can't have a state you can't have a
political society because if if a
government if some
way of organizing politics and
association doesn't ensure people's
safety it just can't be legitimate he
argues it's like a condition of
possibility that's that overlooked
aspect of legitimacy is referring to
right to ensure safety and security yeah
and it's interesting because this is
basically what happens overlooked yeah
that's what happens well i mean it's
overlooked i think in the car like i
think what's overlooked is the
relationship between foundational
legitimacy and what he calls contingent
legitimacy that's innovative yeah so so
i think that the the hobbesian idea
right like to make basically government
the the sovereign is is legitimate
because he prohibits protects from the
war off the war against all against all
exactly so and i think and then
contingent legitimacy are like all the
things that we have after that like
democratic institutions basic rights all
the things that maybe like are kind of
like leftist politics want uh is like
you know like some method
of of of making our will heard and
feeling like we have freedoms to do what
we want
um but ultimately he says all of that
relies on foundational legitimacy um and
i think what i thought was kind of
interesting is i think about some of
like the radical political theory that i
that i work on in my own um research
like radical democracy and some
anarchist thought and i guess and maybe
i mean i've been talking for a while but
maybe you guys will agree or disagree
but i sometimes wonder whether a lot of
leftist
radical theory just wants the contingent
legitimacy but doesn't care about the
foundational legitimacy or at least they
think that it doesn't matter they're
like we can have
you know uh democracy and you know and
egalitarianism and we don't need to
worry about
you know some
state that actually ensures safety um
before we get to
the definitions of these types of
legitimacy can you just give us the
stakes of the article well the point of
the article is really just asking us
like when we have a moment of crisis and
actually he brings up a gambin right
which we talked about in the early days
of of our podcast one of our first
episodes was about agon's take on the
kovit 19 pandemic as a state of
exception right the idea being that like
when there's a crisis moment governments
can use that state of exception to
basically like withhold
uh like
certain like rights and democratic
freedoms and stuff like that i subtitled
this against nightmare
right under on my notes but he's saying
that the state of exception here is
climate change exactly exactly so
climate change is the example he uses to
say look like the chances of us actually
solving it
uh through democratic means right where
we can all agree and and you know
have all that kind of legitimacy that
that intuitively we like like like
consent and democratic deliberation like
the chances of that actually leading to
climate change are so low that
eventually maybe we're actually going to
need to switch back to that foundational
legitimacy where the government just
uses says oh for us to actually be like
a legitimate government we have to solve
climate change like screw
your basic rights screw your democratic
rights because this is the foundational
legitimacy that's kind of how he argues
it
and one of his examples is from the
handmaid's tale where it's obviously a
dystopian terrible fascist theocratic
state but they think but they cut carbon
emissions by like 78 percent
no matter what bad they did at least
they took care of the existential threat
to the species
[Laughter]
yeah so i don't know and and i think and
just quickly like the reaction to this
article i think a lot of people were
outraged as i mentioned before there's
been a lot of like tweets kind of
arguing about how he's trying to justify
i think at the end toward the end of the
article he lays out some examples of
things that could be done like the what
kind of way it might look like
authoritarian action on climate change
um he kind of describes what it would
look like right and he says uh where is
it here
maybe we could you know put put limits
on meat
consumption because that has uh climate
change the government could just outlaw
you know uh the consumption of meat
maybe the government could come in and
uh put limits on misinformation right so
censorship on climate denialism right
like all these things he basically says
might be necessary uh
to maintain what he calls again
foundational legitimacy to maintain
preserving safety for the human race
yeah that's not good but but i i just i
kind of just want to know
because our kind of like climate change
like like like the our main climate
change guy here is eric and i was really
curious what eric thought of this of
this paper yeah
i really enjoyed
having
an intuition of mine as a non-sort of
political theory uh addressing
environmentalism kind of person i
i enjoyed having that sort of put up
here is to say that you know
you know authoritarian governments do
have you know much more
much more room for movement when it
comes to
putting you know restrictions on
freedoms and and controlling markets and
things like that in order to you know
achieve some sort of goal reduction of
carbon emissions or control containing
pandemic outbreaks and things like that
like you would think that
authoritarian governments have the
lateral room to do that and that
democracies do not because they operate
slowly everything calls for due process
and input
and that democracies are going to be
fundamentally a lot less capable of
responding to
to emergencies and evolving situations
than authoritarian governments because
they can just pivot into you know
different solutions because they have a
top-down model as opposed to a
supposedly bottom-up democratic model
and so it's really nice to have that
sort of intuition
and like formalized and investigated and
treated
from the perspective of somebody who
studies you know political theory so i
really enjoyed it in that sense um
i mean it was nice because as i was
reading it too i would think of
objection and then lo and behold you
know the objection would sort of be
addressed in a way right like what about
people who don't care about foundational
literate uh legitimacy right what about
people who
say as he quotes give me liberty or give
me death
like dealing with those sorts of
divergences from the line of thinking
here is is
really interesting too
because you know they are real sorts of
perspectives people have some a lot of
people seem to think you know i'd i
would rather be dead than have my
freedom restricted in any way and you
know that's that's an actual kind of
political subjectivity that you have to
deal with
when you're coming up with these sorts
of
i don't know how to describe it sort of
these are sort of more abstract levels
political theorizing yeah that reminds
me of pills videos are really just
rorschach tests to get people to react
to things there's nothing really there
he saw i could tell the author knew this
criticism was coming about democracy
but he treats and i think we all treat
democracy
as this
sacred cow
the one thing that you can never
question because it's written in the
sacred text democracy is a thing that we
can never dispense with which is kind of
a weird idea because you know
hegel didn't hegel thought we could have
freedom without democracy plato thought
if we had democracy we'd certainly not
be free nietzsche thought democracy was
just for for [ __ ] anyway so there's a
there's an open question about democracy
that well it's not just democracy though
it's also freedom that like like
what the claim i'm making here i guess
it's a semiotic case is that we we imbue
democracy as if it's the only possible
model of freedom that can exist
um
when i don't think that liberty and
democracy are the same thing especially
if you look at actually existing
democracies as we've been talking about
actually existing socialism and
that demands that you allow yourself
with the common turn actually existing
democracy is very undemocratic and also
very unfree so what what is it that
we're defending as this sacred political
theory
um line in the sand that can never be
washed away by the waves because it's
doing so well for us already
i'd just like to make a historical point
though before we go too far down uh that
line of reasoning which is that's really
an unprecedented situation um robert
dahl who is a very well-known political
scientist and probably the ex-world
expert in democracy at the time of his
death he pointed out and i think this is
really true that if you were to ask
anyone up until about the mid-19th
century uh what the worst system of
government was uh and almost any
educated person would tell you democracy
right and this is a line of thought that
goes really all the way back to plato
right uh where you know democracy is
despained as demagoguery and the rule by
the lesser over the better you name it
and there are all kinds of objections of
the swarm in the history at least of
european uh or western ruled by the
uneducated mob is the
most common so i don't want to act like
this isn't a fragile paradigm shift uh
as though somehow this has been a sacred
cow for a very long time it's really
quite unprecedented it's new yeah so and
i think this is also why some people are
a little bit reserved about these
attacks on democracy precisely because
it's really only been in the last 40
years that most countries in the world
have not even nominally become
democracies and i say nominally right
and only again in the last 150 years
where you would see maybe 200 years
serious political theorists defended uh
as a viable form of government
most of them including planning through
the 19th century would say why would you
want democracy it's the worst of all
possible worlds
do you want joe the plumber uh telling
you what to do [ __ ] him you know what i
mean do you political guys is it is
there any case to be made that this is a
product of the cold war that's saying we
are this shining city on a hill
christianity is embodied in the united
or the american state and all the other
bad ones are not democracies sure i
think that's proud of it yeah there's
that's definitely part of it but i did
want to say like so just to kind of
clarify sort of like what we mean
because i think democracy
you know i mean it's a slippery term um
but like in terms of what the author is
actually talking about when he says kind
of like the things that we normally
think about as what he calls contingent
legitimacy so you know um or in general
people like the dominant view is
certainly that like political legitimacy
requires uh and this is like the more
what he calls the moralized view right
um consent democracy equal
representation protections of the
individual rights social justice
or most often some ad mixture of these
factors right so so so that's kind of
like
succinctly saying like what he's what
he's after when he says
uh the the kind of dominant view the
moralizing view right that like
political legitimacy that you have to
have that in order for something to be
legitimate you have to have some mixture
of those things well it's like it's like
democracy and authoritarian have a
common basis in foundational legitimacy
right like authoritarian government you
know any form of government has to have
safety and security for its people right
otherwise it's just a slave state like
even under authoritarians people are
like i've seen the mad max
that's not true
right well
no seriously though like like the
contingent
legitimacy is almost everything that's
over and above uh safety 5630
and in times of like i said earlier in a
different context but you know in times
of peace and and stability right
foundational legitimacy kind of
falls into the background we're not so
concerned about our survival and our
safe basic safety we're concerned with
our values and having those values
reflected in the overall political
conversation so contingent legitimacy is
a series of factors
that are contingent upon the values
and the sorts of needs and desires
over and above safety and security that
characterize
a culture or a people in a time and a
place and they're subject to change and
he seems to be saying that you know a
lot of the things that we take for
granted about democracy are actually
contingent
upon
different value systems so you know that
everyone every human being is equal and
has a set of basic rights would be a
contingent legitimacy thing which
appears
you know again in times of peace and and
and and
lack of concern for our safety you know
these things seem like universals that
they're just always true how could i
ever go to a place that doesn't value
human rights and then when in times of
crisis or and change you know uh those
those things come
out as you know contingent again like he
says and the found the the foundational
legitimacy then comes to the fore
but i mean
he also mentioned uh other examples of
things that are that used to contribute
to contingent legitimacy right he said
uh you know it used to be important that
the leader the king was part of some
lineage right that that went back to um
i guess was it jesus christ or like or
or had some time right
right so like so like the closer that a
king like was more legitimate if you
could if you could somehow trace their
lineage back like closer back to adam i
mean
it's just like joke that's exactly what
robert palmer did in de patriarca right
which john locke famously responded to
the whole point of de patriarca was to
say like look you know god gave birth to
adam and god was adam's daddy and so god
is in charge of adam but then adam was
in charge of cain and abel because he
was their daddy and then everyone's
daddy kind of continues down the line
until we have our big daddy today who's
the king and he was granted control by
his daddy and he's supposed to be in
control but i mean a lot of people have
characterized this as a kind of green
fascism uh i don't think it is kind of
green
i think this is just an argument for a
kind of mildly liberal authoritarianism
that's a lot more like something what
jason brennan would argue for uh and
against democracy a kind of apostocratic
rule by
e eco-elites if you want to be critical
or equal knowledgeable but isn't it
isn't it also just an argument about
like this distinction about legitimacy
too he's kind of like you know if
it's kind of like an observation about
like
and i think like i was actually thinking
about this in in the context of sort of
like more like radical political theory
like leftist political theory it seems
to me i mean maybe this is wrong but but
it sometimes seems to me like
like some like radical political theory
almost wants to deny uh foundational
legitimacy as like being like like the
most important thing or like the thing
that we're like
i mean in some ways are our anarchists
not like denying uh foundational
legitimacy like that like that i think
they have a different conception of
foundational legitimacy right one that's
located in absolute autonomy and i mean
we brought up wolf earlier on and put on
something all right all right all right
let's not go further with the name
dropping i'm sorry i know this is your
area you have a lot to say about it but
let's just stick to the hypothetical of
the article now we have a bunch of
nominal democracies bumbling around at
the climate change summit in scotland
nothing gets done
biden falls asleep
do we now get to do on authoritarianism
for the good of all
potential future democratic subjects
which means
sit down and shut up we are
nationalizing
fossil fuels we are limiting how much
red meat you can eat and how far you can
drive your car
is this what has to happen now to
maintain legitimacy well he says okay so
he defines authoritarianism early he
says uh authoritarian in a fairly
generic and expansive sense through
throughout to refer to political
arrangements or modes of governance that
are illiberal i.e rights and freedom
constraining uh undemocratic and
characterized by a concentration of
executive power getting the vaccine
[ __ ] you but this is what i'm getting at
because what occurred to me originally
is when it comes to these kinds of
questions about who's going to address
social problems including ecological
problems what immediately came to my
mind was uh the sen paradigm uh
marchessam wrote a very famous book uh
uh sorry book on famines right where he
pointed out that one of the things that
distinguishes democrats from
authoritarians is democrats at least
have to give a [ __ ] about their people
to a certain extent which means they
have a certain degree of incentives to
actually try to manage social problems
which means even if they do that slowly
you can be guaranteed that at least
everyone's voice is going to be
nominally listened to and there's going
to be some interest shown in their
well-being including i would argue on
ecological issues potentially
you don't necessarily have the same
level of responsiveness in authoritarian
regimes which very quickly become
kleptocratic and inefficient uh because
they don't have any need to respond to
and the interest of anything more than
the group that basically holds them in
power but do you think that's actually
true actually that doesn't seem true of
existing like i think that but i think
that a lot doesn't seem true of all
authoritarian regimes like china
no it doesn't it doesn't seem true
either that's like it's true so i think
because isn't i mean isn't his point to
about foundational legitimacy that it
actually requires providing safety and
security means that like to some extent
you care about the people right because
like as soon as you can't guarantee i
mean even machiavelli i think like talks
about this stuff right like the moment
that you can't ensure that like you're
in trouble as a leader right it's like
you have to care about safety and
security otherwise like you're [ __ ] it
doesn't matter what kind of regime you
have sure but this is the point that sen
makes about famines right which is that
uh there was an argument made in the
1970s and 1980s that authoritarian
regimes might be better at dealing with
famines uh because
for exactly all the reasons listed in
this article right uh they didn't have
to go through all these democratic
procedures they could be immediately
responsive to the people uh they have
more powers at their behest in order to
try to give food to the people and he
said that most authoritarian regimes
actually did really badly compared to
democracies including in developing
countries when it came to resolving
famines
and the reason is because democratic
regimes had at least some impetus to
have to care for the people they didn't
always and they didn't always do so
successfully but on balance they did
better than their competitors uh now i
don't think that that's true of all
authoritarian regimes and i think china
and singapore are really problem cases
but again if you look at this as applied
to the environmental issue i don't think
the eco record of most authoritarian
regimes is really all that glowing right
russia belarus
i would argue also china haven't done a
comparably good job in fact many times
in gateways they've done a worse job of
environment
managing environmental issues than
democratic states so i'm not sure the
empirical case has been made for his
perspective i think there's an important
distinction to be made here because you
know that's an important perspective to
take on what he's saying here
but it's also characteristic of a lot of
the
a lot of the reaction especially from
sort of mainstream political sciences
that there's no empirical data to back
up these claims to evaluate whether
democracies are doing better than
authoritarian
governments although i would argue that
there is an empirical data and that's
that we're doing at least marginally
better i mean if you look at the uh i
don't think that's clear
it's not clear at all well i mean and
yeah and where is that data coming from
and how much can we trust it and all
those sorts of questions that go into
the empirical side but what about covet
i mean kobe is a good example china did
like did way better
than everybody
but you know but russia and
brazil
and turkey
iran again a number of other sort of
empiricist data different approach is
part of the problem because the re the
problem with the reaction to this
article
because the point of bringing political
legitimacy into this because the bottom
line point here is that if democracies
fail to deal with climate change in the
future not the past that's where our
data comes from our data comes from the
past
if in going into the future if
democracies fail to deal with this and
governments fundamentally are based on
some form of legitimacy then you know
the failure to maintain the safety and
security of its people will
de-legitimize democracy
as a political option
right and that's the bigger danger he's
pointing to that you need to adopt some
authoritarian measures
which he often expresses as relaxing
certain democratic procedures or certain
democratic assumptions we have to relax
certain ones adopt certain level of
authoritarianism which i don't see how
telling people not to eat [ __ ]
cheeseburgers every day is authoritarian
at all sorry that's flippant but i mean
you know don't drive 19
pre-1972 [ __ ]
like muscle cars that get one mile to
the gallon don't do that oh that's very
authoritarian okay but whatever we need
a little bit of that in here if we're
going to save democracy he says to be
clear the argument presented here
shouldn't is not an endorsement of
authoritarianism but a warning should we
wish to avoid legitimating authoritarian
politics we must do all we can to
prevent emergencies from arising that
can only be solved with such means so
the real question is can we solve
climate change
just based on democratic means alone or
do we need some authoritarian you know
input
into
our
approach to the climate emergency thank
you should be called for getting us back
on point
no that's a really important point and i
think that's the point that a lot of the
reaction missed right a lot of the
reactions they all say he's just he's
just endorsing authoritarianism full
stop he's like that's like the essence
of the reaction and it was surprising
because some of those statements came
from like like tenured political
scientists at various universities the
scientists being being the key word
there that's the thing and they're not
political theorists the empirical people
the people based on historical data
let's go look at the track records and
then evaluate the argument like okay
that's a legitimate way of approaching
it but that's not the [ __ ] point of
the evaluation ground that we should be
using for this argument because it's not
a data-driven empirical argument that's
what matt's doing too so he's going to
defend himself yeah matt's going back to
it but it's part of the problem with the
reaction is taking that perspective
that's exactly what he says at the
beginning of the article and by the way
it's also implicit in the argument of
the people he appeals to people like
jason brennan right which is that if
you're going to argue for
whether democracy or whether or not soft
authoritarianism or apostocratic
authoritarianism resolves the climate
traces more effectively
and secures foundational legitimacy in
that respect that is ultimately an
empirical question right
and i absolutely agree with you that
there's no way of knowing whether or not
whether we adopted the measures he's
talking
can actually
have the advantages he's discussing
because we don't have data about the
future but we do have data about the
past and it's shown that the case for
these kinds of measures isn't exactly a
unanimous or clear
we should implement them because it is
actually going to be more effective in
fact i would argue that on balance when
it comes to whether or not democratic
procedures or whether or not
authoritarian procedures are more
effective at securing the conditions for
foundational legitimacy generally or
actually advancing environmentally
friendly policies holy [ __ ] i am getting
don't look up vibes from this
conversation right now he's saying
democracy will not be legitimate if
we're extinct no yeah if they've failed
to protect the point i'm trying to make
here is that historically there's really
no evidence that he actually meets the
empirical threshold that he's talking
about in fact i would say the evidence
broadly speaking not in every specific
case but broadly speaking is against him
so he would need to make a much firmer
empirical case which by the way again is
the threshold he establishes at the very
oh he's not but i don't i don't think
till we're all dead and then make your
empirical case then
no no no but no but but matt i agree
with you like he does talk about that as
being an empirical question but i think
like the point he's making about like
the certain kinds of measures that might
be necessary
is specifically for the purpose of
saving democracy so he's like if we're
gonna save contingent legitimacy like
the kinds of things that we care about
these measures might be need i mean
there's a reason why kovid we did not
all go to the voter box and be like okay
like let's let's all consent to these
measures right it's like we have a
government that just decided to put
these measures in um and like and we and
like we don't really we're not really
consenting to them because it's a way of
like preserving and i think he's saying
that like climate change is probably is
potentially going to be one of those
things that we're going to need to
we're going to need to to uh to deal
with by using those measures i don't
know if he's actually
sure i i don't necessarily disagree that
he might be right in some of those
instances and i actually think that
there are mechanisms for instance in the
canadian constitution uh and every
liberal democratic constitution i think
he talks about that too those kinds of
instances
being enacted it's just on the broader
point uh that's kind of raised by of the
in the article about whether there's an
empirical case be made for episodic
authoritarianism uh but he's also but
he's also not but i think maybe he's not
talking about regimes as much right i
mean the first line
in in the in the abstract is is he's not
it's not is are authoritarian regimes
ever legitimate he says is authoritarian
power ever legitimate right so like
using authoritarian power
um
like is that ever legitimate right so
and i think like like democracies can
use authoritarian power i mean you're
right that he does he does also ask the
question of like
are authoritarian governments more like
better at dealing with it and the
baseline is that it's not because of
contingent legitimacy right not
foundational legitimacy if we look at it
from the perspective of foundational
legitimacy then authoritarian power
could be justified
if if it were to be used in the interest
of preserving the safety and security of
people otherwise living in a democracy
right and and the the problem is if we
choose not to use any authoritarian
measures whatsoever
and [ __ ] gets worse she gets [ __ ]
whatever the
the
complex civilization is unable to
continue
then like that's bad on two grounds
because one you know of the obvious
reason that we're all in a [ __ ]
post-apocalyptic wasteland but the other
one is that democracy will no longer be
legitimate because it can't guarantee
the basic safety and security of people
never mind all the other luxuries that
come on top of that like rights and
freedom and liberty and all these sorts
of
terms that are
sort of defined
the point that i would make in response
to that is one of the reasons why the
climate crisis is as bad as it is it's
precisely that political elites don't
feel any need to be responsive to their
citizenry because there aren't
mechanisms in place to actually impose
any kind of sanctions on them for not
actually looking after the interests of
their people uh so i would actually
point to this as an example where we
would need something like more uh
democracy in order to compel political
elites and for that matter also
corporate elites that sounds appealing
to me but there's also no empirical data
to support that either but although
although i will i will say that that's
appealing into it yeah but i would say
that there is some empirical data to
what this back this up and this is the
point that i was getting at again with
famines uh when it comes to the ability
of governments and the willingness of
governments to actually respond to major
large-scale crises that impact their
population generally uh and that require
global responses democracies and
democracies that are more responsive to
their citizens have tended to do better
than authoritarian regimes now this
isn't an argument about taking any of
the kind of steps that he's taken for
suggesting i think there are moments and
the covet example is a good one where
governments should just act and try to
apologize for it later if people are
pissed off uh but if your argument is
there needs to be an empirical case for
why this is going to work you need to
make a very firm empirical case and
while i think this is theoretically
interesting i don't think that there's
any empirical data at all uh to suggest
that this is going to work in the way
that he's talking about but the
empirical case is difficult because then
you get into questions like well do we
really live in a democracy does does
europe or north america contain a
democracy for example i mean that would
be like an empirical question you'd have
to ask do we currently live in a
democracy right now i mean with all the
arguments coming out about the united
states being an oligarchy or democratic
backsliding and things like that there's
pretty good reason to believe that we
don't even live in a democracy so we
have to address this from the level of
theory and not empirical evidence
sure but i mean
let's take the united states as a
paradigm case the united states is the
world's biggest polluter right now uh
there's data after data suggests that a
majority of the american population
wants the government to take more
strident action on climate change really
wants the government to take more
strident action on climate change and
the government isn't taking stride and
action on climate change even with the
election of a democratic candidate those
opinion polls are almost useless because
if you ask them differently and you say
okay are you willing to have an increase
in your taxes of five percent the the
the the it's going to be less than the
majority of that sure which is what's
going to be necessary sure but there is
a democratic willingness to do something
about climate change how what the
trade-offs would be and how complicated
it would have to be you can you can tell
anybody do you want to address a thing
that's bad and they're all there's going
to be a majority opinion to say yes to
that but i mean this overall over the
clock the last couple decades generally
speaking public opinion has moved more
and more in the direction of saying that
we need to take green measures but my
for me the interesting question is why
hasn't that taken place uh and the
argument i would make is it's not
because the american united states is a
failed democracy uh sorry it's not
because the united states is a democracy
and people just aren't interested in
doing anything the reason is and this
has been well backed up by empirical
data again martin jillian's uh study
affluence and interest is a good one
where he points out that the ordinary
citizen who wants to do something about
climate change has almost no impact on
public policy whatsoever uh the koch
brothers have an impact on policy trump
has an impact on policy and people like
the kochs and the trumps have a big
impact on policy but the ordinary person
doesn't right uh and if the united
states were more democratic than it is
right now uh and actually the will of
the people was more directly paid
attention to we probably would have seen
uh more proactive measures on climate
issues uh but we haven't because the
united states is not a sufficiently
democratic country it's an
author quasi-authoritarian plutocracy uh
that doesn't give a [ __ ] about what's
the impact of climate change is going to
be on most of their people right that's
a little that's a little optimistic to
me i mean i it sounds like the article
got it all backwards saying we haven't
actually the reason is uh
that we haven't had enough democracy and
we've had too much authoritarian power i
find that to be i find that to be super
utopian about human beings like i just i
don't think that's true at all i mean
you see these opinion polls it's like
yeah people of course you're like do you
want to address this bad thing
everyone's going to say yes but then
it's like you get into the nitty-gritty
it's like okay like are you cool with
never eating a cheeseburger again are
you cool with raising your taxes by 10
are you cool with actually what's
necessary to actually fix the problem
and [ __ ] your democracy it's not going
to work at all
sure and absolutely there'd be there'd
be difficulties when it comes to
trade-offs but i do think that overall
if you wanted the us government which is
the world's biggest polluter to be more
responsive to the climate crisis and you
compared what elites want the government
to do people like the koch brothers
versus what the average citizen wants
them to do you'd be far better off
trusting the average citizen
than you were the people who are
actually in charge of the us government
right now uh or who actually have an
impact on policy which are the one
percent i agree with all that but i just
i think it's way too optimistic to be
like oh if we had more democracy like
people are gonna and like backing it up
with opinion polls that are that are
like pretty much meaningless like it's
just
i mean you like to actually you have to
pull people on like what's actually
going to be necessary what they're going
to need to give up
and it's like and you know and you you
need adults in the room to be like sorry
you're going to have to give that up
like absolutely and i think these are
circumstances where some of the ideas
he's talking about might actually be
useful uh for instance having something
like an apostocratic cancer uh of
environmental issues like experts who
would mobilize democratic energies uh
and then say okay if this is what you
want us to do this is how we have to
carry it out like it or lump it that
might be some kind of compromise that we
can make right i had a similar like
somewhat similar intuition to you matt
that like
i'm not sure the empirical case because
like my but my i mean my intuition
afterwards was certainly not i mean i'm
convinced that
more democracy like i just don't see
that necessarily being the thing that's
going to solve it
my takeaway
was like yeah i don't think
authoritarianism is going to necessarily
work either because i think there's
going to be all kinds of outrage i i was
just like oh yeah we're [ __ ] like like
my my my reaction to the article was
like nothing's gonna work until it's too
late and like we're only gonna see
action when like the effects are so
undeniable and it's probably gonna be a
point of no return where then it's just
going to be trying to like minimize the
irreversible damage that's already been
done
because like until like i just don't
think that anything like like more
democracy like that's not sure if it can
work
while we're waiting around to talk about
this some more and build democracy
then the asteroid has already hit there
no but here
i think that you've misinterpreted the
point of that movie and i'll explain why
we can get into this morning we're gonna
do that
yeah but i just want to point this out
that movie is about a bunch of ground
ground-level people who desperately want
and have the support of a lot of people
by the way to actually do something
about the asteroid and the people that
[ __ ] them over and say we're not going
to do anything about it
isn't the demos uh it's the rich
[ __ ] who
ariana grande
well yeah well no she sings the song at
the end which is the song which made a
big difference to everybody didn't it
just like this conversation is going to
make a big difference our topic here the
whole you know the movie does why don't
we just do democracy properly we don't
have time for that either but the movie
does a really good job of showing that
that most people in the world including
a lot of americans including grassroots
activists want the government to
immediately do something about this
asteroid uh but it's because whatever is
named elon musk guy uh and the president
decide [ __ ] that we're gonna monetize
that in some way
come what may uh that the whole world
gets destroyed uh so
adam mckay nice democratic socialist
bernie sanders supporter i think would
actually say the point of that movie is
again ordinary people know that this is
a problem and it needs to be solved and
it needs to be solved right [ __ ] away
the problem isn't them the problem is
meryl streep and jonah hill and
elon musk wannabe uh who decided that
the best idea is to send robots up to
mine the damn thing because they think
they can make 50 trillion dollars off of
it you know i think the the point
here the problem with just like you know
evoking the
average ordinary person too is that he
gives plenty of examples of supposed
authoritarian measures that are being
rejected by ordinary people i.e wearing
masks social distancing lockdowns all
these sorts of things that are perceived
as authoritarian measures to combat
covid which he's using as a kind of
microcosm of climate change is that
ordinary people are rejecting them
people but i don't think they are they
are clearly self-identifying
statistically something democratic
and libertarian or whatever like a kind
of radical form of democracy
some people right like some people got
donald trump elected right and he
remains the figurehead of the republican
party yeah but a majority some people
don't like to wear masks and yet they
seem to be dominating right now that
perspective and i think it's better to
look at it in terms of this right we
have okay let's say we let's say for the
sake of argument that we have democracy
but people in those democracies are
rejecting what they're perceiving as
authoritarian measures like lockdowns
for instance i could probably look out
my window and see an anti-lockdown
poster from my [ __ ] living room yet
yeah the problem here is that these
measures are being
perceived as authoritarian and therefore
illegitimate because our baseline for
legitimacy is contingent legitimacy and
not foundational legitimacy lockdown is
going to keep you safe too [ __ ] bad
because it impinges on my freedom so i'm
going to reject it i mean that's the
whole problem is your foundation of what
measures
utilizing kinds of democracies using
authoritarian power to restrict our
movements and our freedoms people are
rejecting that like a gambin does
violently by saying that that's just the
first step towards fascism right and
he's making an argument let's look at it
a different way let's say these measures
are not for these are to preserve the
legitimacy of democracy not to ruin it
not to get rid of it not to destroy it
but to preserve it because if we fail
then authoritarians gonna start looking
real tasty to a lot of people we already
know a lot of leftist folks who are in
the sort of marxist leninist china
sympathizing ambit who would welcome
that yeah kind of yeah kind of
development right and and i don't care
whether it's good or bad whatever [ __ ]
that but he's that's like the argument
he's sort of putting forward right is if
we don't convince people i don't know
he's not trying to convince him if we
don't convince people that these
measures are not a suspension of
democracy but a supplementing democracy
in order to make it work better then
maybe people will be a little more you
know
people will be conducive to going along
with things that the government wants to
say but his wants them to do
and like his his examples are like
pretty modest in my view like you know
epistocracy standard for instance that
governments should act based on the best
available evidence
i mean why aren't we doing that already
that's not authoritarian
i'll bet you when the [ __ ] gets so like
like maybe we can make a little bet now
and we'll see if like 30 40 years who's
right but like i'll bet you
that you know when the climate crisis is
so bad that it's like undeniable the
first countries to take strong measures
is going to be china uh it's gonna be
the authoritarian countries who are
gonna be the first to bring in broad
sweeping changes to try to stem the
bleeding
um and we're gonna be [ __ ] holding
our dicks you know taking our time
deliberating about what the best way to
do it is yeah here's some empirical
evidence china saw that video games were
bad for kids and they stopped them from
playing it
good good move china i like it i like it
i mean didn't they used to have like
those wow world of warcraft farms like
located there where you could get a
career just playing warcraft and well
it's only kids understand going to
college so you have to be 18 before
you're allowed to wow farm or whatever
league of legends farm whatever it is
now these days
i'm sorry i'm sorry i got angry about
that kind of thing no no it's not cool
i never object to you getting angry i
object to you
taking the air out of something
interesting and making it about this
micro thing that i don't even recognize
i didn't even see it that's why i was
getting frustrated that's fair but i i
do want to stand by to my point that i
do think
the empirical case needs yeah yeah we
know we know
we got it
all right we're gonna wrap it up i don't
think okay i noticed this because we got
um there's ratings on spotify now and we
have never asked this before but we do
have an ask
because i searched philosophy and our
podcast didn't show up because it
doesn't have enough you know clicks or
or whatever
so if you're listening to this and if
you like us and even if you don't like
us
help a brother out give us a five star
and write about how this has changed
your life on whatever podcast
thing you're looking for
um even if we don't deserve five stars
even if you think worth three stars
for today we're five stars and then
we'll make a commitment to you to get up
to five stars eventually okay and if we
haven't changed your life yet it's
coming it's my uh
as plastic pills that we will eventually
change your life if you think we
actually only deserve three stars um but
you put five stars like dm pills no no
no dm if you have negative feedback
matt is on twitter
he would be happy to debate you um until
you're done
yeah however long it takes so all
negative feedback goes to matt mcmanus
on twitter and all positive feedback
goes to whatever you're listening to
this on thank you i appreciate it thank
you very much if we get to five stars
i'm gonna [ __ ] solve the question
i really will i start getting bombarded
by like nasty things i'm not i'm gonna
go like full like oh by the way this is
his address just mail everything to him
oh you got to put that that message
acceptance thing on twitter where you
have to approve it before you actually
get it
i mean i hope you have that
you have that right yeah
yeah no
wow
all right well we'll wrap it up there
that was a bit of a grab bag episode but
we had a lot of catching up to do so uh
thank you to all our listeners
patrons don't worry something's coming
out soon we're trying to get it done
this week yeah and
if and ross mitiga if you're listening
to this you know let us know uh let us
know how much matt got it wrong or if or
or
you can come on the pod we promise matt
won't be here well
no we'll send him out
we'll send back to interviews brennan
are you kidding me if anything i should
be the one here we'll hop in a bit and
we'll have a long argument and
eventually
i will just grind him down to the ground
uh through sheer exhaustion
[Laughter]
you guys can open up your excel sheets
and bring off the data
uh thanks guys it was a good talk let's
get to uh
oh [ __ ] we're at an hour and four yeah
okay yeah let's definitely stop it just
be a bit of an edit all right see you
guys
wrapping up
bye
[Music]
okay